merci la parole et à monsieur bernard
perrut monsieur le premier ministre
tout début d'année est propice aux
bilans et aux projets un triste bilan
pour le gouvernement dans beaucoup de
domaines et les français s'interrogent
sur vos priorités
à l'heure où le chômage n'a jamais été
aussi important deux cent cinquante
mille demandeurs d'emploi de plus en
2015 il s'accroît chaque jour sans que
vous preniez les mesures qui s'imposent
c'est le chômage qu'il faut alléger
monsieur le premier ministre
pas l'orthographe c'est le code du
travail qu'il faut réformer par les
horaires d'ouverture de pôle emploi dans
les communes c'est l'apprentissage que
vous avez massacré et il faut soutenir
pas les seuls contrats aidés qui ne
conduisent pas une formation et un vrai
emploi les jeunes trop nombreux a galéré
désespère donner l'impression d'agir
sans rien changer sur le fond ne suffit
pas lancer le grand chantier de la
réforme du droit du travail sans toucher
aux contrats aux licenciements en temps
de travail ne convainc pas pourquoi ne
pas réformer comme l'ont fait nos
partenaires européens qui réussissent et
faire confiance aux chefs d'entreprises
artisans commerçants qui veulent moins
de charges et de normes plus de
souplesse pour plus d'activités et plus
de commandes l'emploi mes chers
collègues ne se décrète pas en affirmant
vouloir forêt cinq cent mille personnes
sans qu'il y ait cinq cent mille emplois
vous tromper les français monsieur le
premier ministre en renvoyant aux grands
chantiers de réformes vous saper la
confiance car il ya pour vous l'urgence
toujours urgence à agir plus tard pour
la baisse de charges pérennes top pour
le nouveau code du travail
ce sera pour 2018 monsieur le premier
ministre
entendez-vous la désespérance vos
concitoyens et qu'allez vous faire
oui qu'allez vous faire pour favoriser
la croissance et soutenir l'économie
telle est notre demande sur ces bancs et
elle à la demande de tous les français
merci la parole est à madame myriam el
khomri minutieux travail de l'emploi de
la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bernard perrut quand nous annonçons que
nous allons réécrire les 125 pages du
code du travail sur le temps de travail
qu un sujet très concret pour les
employeurs et les salariés
vous considérez que c'est une réforme a
minima quand nous descendons nous
décidons de restructurer les branches
professionnelles 700 on en parle depuis
30 ans et qu'on passe à 200 d'ici deux
ans et à 400 d'ici la fin d'année
jusqu'où peut aller et vous n'avez fait
que nous proposons un changement radical
d'approché consistant à laisser plus de
place à la négociation collective de
branche et d'entreprise
vous dites que vous nous allons pas
assez loin vous voyez bien monsieur le
député qu'aucun gouvernement n'a proposé
une réforme de telle ampleur est
justement
quant à la commission qui va réécrire
complètement le code du travail
sachez que c'est un travail colossal qui
demandent véritablement ce travail
essentiel et ça prend du temps en effet
ça prendra deux ans pourquoi parce que
c'est bien une réforme qui est
importante
défaits ce rapport badinter
à partir de là c'est tout le champ de la
négociation développons je présenterai
mon projet loi le 9 mars et nous aurons
en conseil des ministres le 9 mars et
nous aurons l'occasion d'échanger ici
par ailleurs vous parlez de
l'apprentissage il ya eu beaucoup de
réformes de l'apprentissage
mais quand je vous entends encore ici
sur ces bancs dire qu'on ne peut pas
pour un apprenti boucher on peut pas
avoir un couteau pour un jeune on peut
pas monter sur des échelles et que pour
un jeune apprenti boulanger on ne peut
pas travailler dès 4 heures du matin
c'est faux et c'est faux et vous
justement vous permettez à avec ces
propos là ça ne donne pas envie à des
employeurs de s'engager dans la queue
dans le cadre de l'apprentissage
il ya des décrets qui ont été pris
depuis deux ans pourrait y laisser
question
continuez continuez à dire ce type de
choses
les apprentis restent sur le carreau et
ne trouve pas d'employeur à cause de ce
type de propos qui sont toujours
prononcés dans ce titre nous vous le
voyez bien aux réformes des réformes
conjoncturelles avec le préformateur
aller s'il vous plaît on nageait